eine woche lang verschwundene spurlos
die 14 jahre alte josephine aus
aschersleben in sachsen anhalt in dieser
sendung haben wir gestern zur suche
aufgerufen und jetzt ist josefine
gefunden tot in einer garage auf einem
garagenhof lag ihre leiche ein
verbrechen und wir wollen einmal ein
blick auf die karte werfen wo genau hat
sich dieses offenbare verbrechen
abgespielt der fundort der liegt in
sachsen anhalt das ganze verbrechen
spielt sich ab in aschersleben und die
leiche von josefine sie wurde eben dort
in dieser garage gefunden recht sehen
sie das eingezeichnet der fundort und er
ist ungefähr zwei kilometer entfernt von
diesem treffpunkt dort wollte sie sich
treffen mit ihrem ex freund dort war sie
verabredet und wir haben auch gerade
links auf der karte noch gesehen ihr
wohnort also diese tat offenbar die hat
sich abgespielt auf einer relativ
kleinen fläche und doch hat es eben über
eine woche jetzt gedauert um josef eine
josefines leiche zu finden dort in
aschersleben wir gehen genau dorthin in
diese an diese garage in aschersleben zu
unserem kollegen thilo scholtyseck grüße
dich thilo
guten morgen sagen machen hier wo die
polizei bittet tief
hat zwei verzeichnet dennoch eine eine
frage natürlich zum einstand vor allen
dingen wer und wann wurde josef ines
leiche dort an der garage in der garage
gefunden
josefine ist leiche wurde gestern gegen
14 uhr 30 von
anwohnern gefunden die hier auch eine
garage haben der komplex ist sehr groß
sie gibt es 160 garagen die meisten sind
relativ verfallen wir haben mir gerade
leute erzählt diese garagen haben die
auch vor ort sind dass es hier hofft
einbrüche gibt viele garagen stehen leer
und offensichtlich in so einer leer
stehenden garage hier hinter mir wo
alles abgesperrt ist wurde die leiche
gefunden die polizei hat die ganze nacht
durch ermittlungen aufgenommen die
feuerwehr kam hat den tatort
ausgeleuchtet damit die
gerichtsmediziner die ermittler hier
ihre spuren sichern konnten wir wissen
dass heute weitere suchmaßnahmen hier
geben wird man sucht immer noch nach dem
handy von josefine es gibt hier in der
nähe auch in see wo man vielleicht
vermuten dass es da reingeschmissen
boden sein könnte da kommen heute
vielleicht sogar noch taucher zum
einsatz
welche hinweise gibt es ansonsten dort
am fundort
es ist
hier noch alles abgesperrt weil die
polizei auch heute weiter hier suchen
wird in dem bereich der garage
man konzentriert sich wirklich jetzt
erstmal auf die spurensicherung es gibt
wie ich gerade von der polizei erfahren
habe noch keinen konkreten tatverdacht
ist wird einfach weiter gesucht man
guckt jetzt was man hier noch findet
natürlich läuft die auswertung der
spuren die die tatortgruppe gestern
gesichert hat im landeskriminalamt die
leiche wird obduziert die es noch in der
nacht abtransportiert worden und man hat
gesagt es wird heute wahrscheinlich im
laufe des tages auch weitere entwicklung
geben und da müssen wir einfach abwarten
wie sich die dinge entwickeln noch
keinen konkreten tatverdacht sagst du
gerade thilo irgendwie steht ja schon
der ex freund dort im mittelpunkt mit
ihm war sie verabredet an diesem tag und
kehrte in nie wieder zurück und dann
wird ihre leiche jetzt auch nicht ganz
so weit entfernt zwei kilometer entfernt
von diesem treffpunkt der beiden
gefunden warum hat es so lange gedauert
ihn möglicherweise mehr in den
mittelpunkt der ermittlungen zu stellen
oder warum hat er steht er nicht unter
tatverdacht
muss sagen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist es
wirklich so er ist ein zeuge er wurde
mehrfach von mehr wurde mindestens vier
mal vernommen immer im beisein seiner
eltern es handelt sich bei dem jungen
erst 15 jahre alt ja noch um einen nicht
volljährigen
deshalb
hat die polizei auch in
übereinstimmung mit den eltern
freiwillig einer durchsuchung der
wohnung vorgenommen hier hat die familie
selber keine garage man guckt jetzt wmd
zugeordnet werden kann deshalb hier gibt
es verschiedene wild kameras die die
garagenbesitzer angebracht haben das
material dieser kameras wertet die
polizei auch aus weil man natürlich
hoffnung hat vielleicht irgendwelche
bewegungsbilder zu sehen ob man sehen
kann dass hier jemand angekommen ist in
den letzten tagen denn immerhin ist ja
josephine seit donnerstag dem vierten
november verschwunden gewesen thilo
scholtyseck unser reporter dort am
fundort der leiche von josef in
aschersleben vielen herzlichen dank und
wir wollen weiter über diesen fall
sprechende mit kriminalist christian
matzdorf uns jetzt direkt auch
zugeschaltet er wird analysieren was der
fundort aussagen könnte über diese tat
schönes sie bei uns in kontakt stoff der
fundort was könnte der aussagen über
diese tat
der fundort ist für die
kriminalistischen ermittlungen genauso
bedeutend wie der noch nicht bekannte
tatort vielleicht sind auch von dort und
hat identisch das müssen wir heute wohnt
hat noch nicht dieser ort ist natürlich
ein
fundus an spuren und ergibt
möglicherweise hinweise darauf ob die
täter oder der täter ein bezug zu diesem
ort hatten also hatten selber gerade
gesagt ist diese garage einer person
zuzuordnen ist dieser bereich dort
vielleicht personen oder personengruppen
zuzuordnen das alles ist relevant für
die haben momentan und da ja auch der
einsatz der technik die natürlich jetzt
alle spuren arten von dna-spuren
möglicherweise dax-kurve spuren
vielleicht faserspuren hier auswertet
nachdem sie die gesichert haben sie
haben sich den fall genau angeschaut
hermsdorf wenn sie die fotos sehen vom
fundort der leiche von josefine wenn sie
die geschichte mit dem ex freund kennen
ja die beiden waren verabredet was ist
jetzt auch anhand der fotos die
entscheidende spur die sie weiter
verfolgen würden
was die beziehungs situation des
mädchens anbelangt muss man vorsichtig
sein wir dürfen nicht
wir dürfen nicht spekulieren
selbstverständlich wir wissen aber aus
der kommunistischen erfahrungen mit auch
aus der kriminologischen theorie dass
insbesondere frauen ganz besonders
gefährdet sind in trennungssituationen
das gilt regelfall für erwachsene
menschen in situationen die unter
erwachsenen sich ergeben trennung nach
entsprechende beziehung das ist aber
auch bei jugendlichen nicht
auszuschließen also insofern ist das
hier sicherlich eine spur die die
polizei mit hochdruck verfolgen wird
spekulieren dürfen wir nicht was den ort
selber angeht ist natürlich geeignet um
einen leichten damen für eine gewisse
zeit zu verbergen sicherlich nicht
geeignet um dauerhaft in leichten dort
zu belasten also man muss schon
überlegen was täter oder täterinnen
weiter vorgehabt haben das heißt wir
müssen in die kriminalistische thesen
bildung reingehen und müssen über
verschiedene varianten verschiedene
alternativen hier prüfen abwägen und das
macht die polizei gerade mit hochdruck
vielen herzlichen dank dafür ihre
einschätzungen zu diesem fall
gerne